all right now we head back to the
repulsive political stun from beto bozo
o'rourke who interrupted a very
important briefing about juvalde and the
shooting that took place and he was then
confronted by the city's mayor watch
this
excuse me
this is totally
[Music]
i can't believe you're a sick son of a
[ __ ] would come to a deal like this to
make a political
[Music]
[Music]
like you why issue you get out of here
here with more is the mayor of uvalde
don mclaughlin is with us mr mayor first
our sincere apologies love prayers and
and thoughts are with you and your
entire community we're so sorry this
happened to everybody there uh thank you
for being with us in this tough time
um
i want to ask you first and foremost
about
that moment were there were there family
members that lost loved ones in that
room at that time
it's too important
that i don't know that i don't know but
that was not the time or place to have
that discussion if he wants to have that
discussion that's fine but today if that
conference was not the time or place to
do that
it wasn't but there were parents there
there were people crying i understand
parents in the audience is that correct
yes there was
yeah yes so it was
when you when you first saw this and and
obviously you took it upon yourself to
stand up and tell them to shut up
uh and and i think rightly resonated
with a lot of people in the country by
calling them an sob
it's a clear political stunt
but even before we knew how many people
had actually been killed
in your community already the president
of the united states had spoken out
about this and politicized this
and i have a hard time understanding
without any knowledge or even a death
count in a tragedy like this why people
race and rush to politicize it what are
your thoughts on that
well first and foremost our hearts are
broken here in your body my heart's
broken for these families that lost
these children won't come back but
that's the problem
every time we have one of these it's a
political deal what happened to the
grown men that we elected to represent
us in congress that can't sit down at a
table and come to a conclusion i'm not
going to get 100 of what i want you're
not going to get 100 what you want but
nobody wants to have that discussion
it's either going to be my way or the
highway and we keep politicizing this
and yes
we have a gun problem sure do we need an
expanded bank trump background check
possibly but we also have a mental
health problem that nobody wants to
address and maybe maybe we don't have
any signs today from that young man but
it could have been there two years ago
that he could have reached out and we
could have gave him some help we'll
never know that
you know mr
21 families are suffering
mr mayor
4598 kids have been shot and killed in
the united states since 2019.
of the smallest percentage of them are
school shootings i'm a believer that god
creates every human life and every human
life
is precious and we need to preserve and
protect it uh as far as school shootings
specifically go
i think the time has now come where we
must protect our kids the way we protect
uh hollywood stars and our elected
officials that have armed security with
them is
is that a possible answer for example in
your community
yeah i mean we we formed the police we
farmed the police department you've
already consolidated independent school
district farm a police department you
know thank god there was one there to
you know one there when he was
well that was yes we need to put armed
security guards in our armed police
officers in our schools
i think i think it should be mandatory
and i think our children deserve what
are for example d.c elected officials
have and by the way we pay for it and i
think it's the right thing to do i think
we've got to protect our elected
officials uh but i also believe we got
to protect our children also and i also
believe that we're not doing a good job
you know here uvalde is getting lectures
from uh politicians and the very same
people that ignore the violence in
chicago and baltimore and d.c and la and
new york uh i don't really think you
need lectures from people that haven't
cleaned up their own backyard what do
you think
no i agree with you totally i mean i
spent some time in chicago i spent three
months there when i went through a
cancer treatment and and every weekend
it was 10 to 15 deaths you could buy a
gun in chicago you can't buy bullets in
chicago but yet look at look at what
happens there every weekend it's a
tragedy we need to address
we we need to address these shootings we
need to address a lot of things but the
gun control they're talking that's not
going to stop these people from getting
those guns they're going to get them
however they want we need to come to a
table sit down and come to something
that's going to work for everybody
mr mayor i know you had your vigil
tonight and i know it's been a very
emotional
you know tumultuous you know
48 hours 24 hours for the people in your
your city uh what do what is what
what are the plans for the days to come
do you know yet
we don't our biggest and foremost is
just make sure these families
are cared for their needs are met
whatever they need
you know like i said you know thank god
we did have the state here because we
didn't have the resources to deal with
what we've had to deal with and what
they brought into our community has been
just
uh unbelievable and the outpouring of
love that we've got from all over the
country and the support that we've
gotten you know in the next couple of
days we're going to continue to grieve
but we're also a strong community
you know one one man asked me today said
we'll be stuck with this stigma for the
rest of our lives in uvalde is a place
where school shooting was you know that
may be true but we're not gonna we're
not gonna choose to embrace that that
we're gonna embrace the community that
we are strong
caring and loving for one another
mr barrett now we speak for this
audience a lot of love and prayers in
these very very difficult days for you
and the families especially in the
community uh thank you for being with us
sir hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else